look at how every toronto raptor can get  to their spot and get someone else  involved  giannis trying to push the pedal right  here  and get his team back in it time's  running down  you want him doing this being aggressive  yes he's smart enough to be a  facilitator when the time  lends itself but right now you need a  heavy dose  of the reigning mvp giannis a bad man  especially when he gets it in the paint  powell committed the the foul on giannis  who is two for six at the line  get more action on fanduel and look for  first basket insurance  on select games fanduel gives you more  ways to win with sports betting  daily fantasy and free-to-play games  let's see if his brother knocks on wood  from to make it okay now a little  scotland report  his brother knocks on will before every  free throw can you throw his brother off  of his game and have him  forget let's see if it works it does  it's a family business  that's doing what he can from the  sidelines